the One Piece manga just revealed that
the conclusion of the Egghead island arc
will Shock the World in ways that no one
could have imagined and personally I
take that as a serious challenge with
the Marines rallying their forces to
stop the straw hats at Egghead it is
sure to be one Epic conclusion so buckle
up and let's try to figure out what this
shocking conclusion could possibly be
and to really get to the bottom of this
we first have to of course consider that
the Egghead island arc has many striking
parallels to both the Saba ODI and the
anus Lobby arts and now with the reveals
in this chapter it also has a similar
setup to the greatest war in one piece
history Marine Forts and based on all
these parallels to the pre-time skip I
believe there are three possible
conclusions that would end up shocking
the world the first one would have the
straw hats coming out on top of things
another could finally shed some real
light on the secrets of the white
century and the last one at the end of
this video could result in the biggest
war the story has ever seen I know we're
not going to address my haircut but
instead let's start with all the
parallels between the pre-time skip arcs
and Egghead Islands because it is well
established that ichirota the author of
One Piece takes ideas from the pre-time
skip arcs and then reuses them with some
sort of crucial twist after just one
example is that in Alabaster we had a
warlord trying to take over a kingdom
and then in dressrosa we had a warlord
who had already successfully taken over
that King Oda likes his style of writing
a lot so we can use it to our advantage
to learn more about the current
situation on Eckhart Island as well but
in case you don't believe me let's
compare for a second every single
similarity from Saba ODI in a slavi and
Marine Forge to what is currently
ongoing on Egghead Islands first on Enos
Lobby the straw hats battled the
government secret agent cp923 Robin a
character who has knowledge of the Void
Century cp9 also wanted the blueprints
to pluton the ancient weapon now in
echid Island The Twist to this is that
the straw hats are now allied with
another government Secret Agency zp0 as
they try to protect megapunk another
character who has knowledge of the Void
century and possibly the ancient weapons
similarly in Ms Lobby we have the
flashback to the island of Scholars
O'Hara and in this scene O'Hara was
obliterated because of their Research
into the pony glyphs and the void
century and on echin island we have
another scholar vegapunk who was not
only friends with the researchers on
O'Hara but who also knows much of the
same Forbidden Knowledge The Twist is
that instead of the gorosei ordering
ships to blow up Ohara now the gurusai
are actually coming themselves to take
care of this threat and even worse than
the Buster curl from pre-timescape we
now have the threat of whatever this
ridiculous laser power is instead and
moving on to the Saba oi archipelago Arc
you may have forgotten but the straw
hats actually entered this entire Arc
extremely confidently they had just
taken on the world government at anas
Lobby and survived and now they felt
ready for the new worlds spoiler warning
they weren't and this time they again
entered echid Island equally confident
having just defeated the emperor of the
sea kaido and Luffy becoming an emperor
himself but the twist is that they are
much more prepared to face what is
coming right right so keep watching till
the end of this video to see how they
could be completely overwhelmed and
wiped out once again but moving on for
now Saba ODI was the first time that the
straw hats ever interacted with a
Celestial Dragon and now on eckhit
island we are interacting with a gorosei
for the very first time in the story
though this one will surely be more of a
threat than
whatever this guy was supposed to do and
of course there are also many other
characters from Saba ODI that are once
again making an appearance here on naked
island the Admiral kizaru is here as
well as vegapunk's protector sent
homearu on Saba ODI the straw hats
fought the cyborg Posse feasters for the
very first time and now in ekken Island
they're fighting the upgraded and
genetically engineered seraphim For the
First Time The Warlord Kuma and his
daughter Bonnie were in Saba ODI and
they are both here once again at least
Kuma's memories are and another
similarity comes from marineford where
Luffy tried to save his brother Ace from
execution and now in Egghead it seems
that the war is coming to the straw hats
because in this chapter we are shown
this incredibly similar panel of Marines
gathering for war now when eckhead
Island first began many of us thought
that this Arc would be a very quick stop
before heading right to elbaf clearly
that is not the case as we literally
told that whatever will happen here will
shock the world and if this Arc is
actually going to be an all-out War like
Marine for it it will be helpful to look
at what world shaking events happened
during that battle first Ace who was the
son of the former pirate King was killed
before he died Whitebeard proclaimed
that the one-piece treasure is real and
then Blackbeard gained his second devil
fruit basically we had two very tragic
deaths we had a reveal about the one
piece and a crazy twist with devil
fruits and so now with all these
similarities established what can we
learn that will help us figure out what
will happen at Egghead well I see three
possibilities that would shock the world
for sure first if this truly turns out
to be the world government against the
straw hats and vegapunk then straw hats
being Victorious here would certainly
shock the world for multiple reasons
astride Victory would surely mean that
kizeru and Admiral Was Defeated which is
a ridiculous thing to think about
considering how rarely an admiral has
ever been defeated by a pirate really
the closest thing to that that ever
happened was when Shane's chased away
green bull at the end of wano and I
guess you could also add when Whitebeard
Florida kainu although that battle never
had a true winner and then with green
bull he also just retreated more than he
was to feed it so if the straw hats
could defeat this Lightfoot user it
would certainly cause a stir around the
world and next up are you hungry because
the sponsor of today's video is boxu and
this beautifully designed Japanese snack
box is easily the most mouth-watering
box that they have sent me yet it is a
special limited edition called Sakura
story celebrating cherry blossom season
here in Tokyo which is perfect because
I've developed a fever or kafucho as
it's called in Japanese for the very
first time in my life but with this I
can celebrate Hanami from the safety and
comfort of my home I've actually already
tried a bunch of stuff while filming the
b-roll for this box as is tradition with
a boxu sponsorship and uh these mentiko
Mayo chips are maybe my favorite thing
that they've ever put in the box so I
mean
all of these snacks and tea pairings are
actually made by local Japanese family
businesses like these Sakura cookies I
actually already had one
let's have another one
if you also want to celebrate Hanami at
home this year and support this channel
you can use my code Ohara for 15 of your
very first delicious order
but of course even more shocking than
this would be if the straw hats defeated
not an admiral but Saint Saturn first we
have never seen any of the girls say in
action so seeing send Saturn powers in
action is going to be extremely hype no
matter what it ends up being but imagine
what would happen if the straw hats
actually managed to defeat a gorosei we
have literally no idea what would happen
since it has never been mentioned that
there has ever been a gorosei defeated
or replaced certainly if this actually
happened and the News somehow spread
around the world looking at you big news
Morgan it could lead to unrest all
around the world for example if the
straw hats can defeat one of these
legendary figures who else might try to
take them down as well could dragon and
the revolutionaries finally make their
move against the world Nobles or other
Pirates such as Blackbeard or Shanks it
could even to an all-out Rebellion
against the world government from
countries all around the globe that are
tired of paying the Heavenly tributes
and then there is also Kuma who is
currently on a mission to climb the red
line to reach marijuana now while we
don't know what his real goal is here
there are some similarities that we can
draw Clues from once again I mean do you
remember who else climbed the red line
Fisher tiger this fisherman that we met
during a flashback who freed thousands
of slaves from the celestial dragons
Kuma could be climbing to do the same
but I honestly have no clue who we do
know that Kuma can use his devil fruit
powers to basically teleport anyone
anywhere so he could also be trying to
send someone from the original to eckhad
Islands or maybe he could want to leak
some information about the world's
government and speaking of leaking
information this takes us to our second
major possibility for the shocking
conclusion of eckhead Island and you
won't believe how this one could change
the world while I straw had Victory
would certainly be very notable for the
entire world something even more
disastrous for the world government
itself would be their deepest Secrets
being exposed we know that vegapunk has
knowledge of the Void century and he
could have also learned about the true
identity of the ruler of the world emu
and while he is currently captured by
the mega Punk traitor York there are
many ways that he could still leak this
information first megapunk could have
already recorded it and it could be
waiting in Punk records to be released
on his command or even after his death
plus we've learned in the special volume
that came together with film red that
vegapunk once made a prototype
livestream transponder snail so he could
even broadcast his information to the
entire world and if the whole world were
to find out what he knows it would
undoubtedly cause chaos it's not really
hard to imagine a rebellion since the
world government has worked so hard for
so long to keep all of this information
secrets and besides vegapunks Saint
Saturn himself could also do something
that no one expects now while still
fairly unlikely I personally believe
that there is a not that small
possibility that the gurusi are actually
not as evil as many people think they
are for example they allow Shanks to
come in to discuss a certain pirate and
they've even shown remorse over what
happened on the island of O'Hara on top
of that you have the entire planet
circling around the sun which would
again be Luffy so who knows so what if
Saint Saturn isn't actually here to
fight what if he has come to talk to
Luffy in chapter 1078 we're being told
that the gurusi came here as a backup
measure in case that vegapunk decided to
fight back but what if he really wanted
to meet the newly awakened Joy boy keep
in mind that Joy Boy hasn't awake taken
for 800 years so maybe the gorosei have
been waiting all this time for joyboard
to reappear why would he want to do that
well we could make some crazy theories
such as the guru say feeling bad for
about what happened during the white
century and want to make it right or
another possibility comes from our
previous discussion that the guru say
are named after planets from our solar
system perhaps they want to take orders
around the true center of the universe
Joy boy who represents the Sun instead
of emu who represents the Earth could
emu be forcing them to do all these bad
things and they all want to be free or
are they just trying to rule him in
somehow I know it sounds crazy but
there's actually way more proof for that
than you might think and if you want to
hear that discussion in a future video
make sure to subscribe to the channel
and this already takes us to the third
possibility for the shocking conclusion
of eckat Island which is that the straw
had suffered their worst defeat ever
remember back on sabaori the straw hats
were forcefully scattered all across the
world and in marineford Luffy lost his
brother Ace his lowest point in the
story by far so we have to imagine how
Oda would twist this if the straw hats
were to be defeated once again a few
possibilities include that they could be
separated Again by Esther who possesses
Kuma's devil fruit Powers if this were
to happen again we could have another
whole mini Saga similar to imple down a
marine for it before we make it to
elbeth which I would be on board for and
remember that Luffy's other brother Sabo
is also missing right now so Luffy going
to save Sabo would be a possibility in
that case though a little bit redundant
if we're being honest and an even worse
outcome could of course be one or more
of the straw hats dying I mean while
this might not be shocking for the
entire world the pain it causes would
very much be I mean imagine if usub were
to die or Nami I mean Luffy would go
insane and Destroy literally everything
in his path and another possible outcome
if the straw hats are defeated is that
Luffy could end up captured by the world
government maybe he's taken out by some
mysterious power that since Saturn uses
or maybe the straw hats are about to be
killed and Luffy trades himself to save
his crew I mean for example a few of
them have just been turned to stone
either way Luffy being captured is
definitely a real possibility and
another Marine Fort style execution
would definitely shock the world and
this would certainly lead us to another
even bigger all-out War than what we
already have Brewing at eckat Island
right now when all of Luffy's allies
come to his rescue I mean just imagine
Shanks Dragon the grand Fleet and
everyone else who could come to save
Luffy it would be utter insanity and if
you want to see how that battle might
play out you can actually watch this
video right here thanks for watching